what the left is attempting to do is
paint
all of us with that brush that the
left's behavior over the last week
has really been a in a justification
of trump's long stated rationale for his
own power which is
he says the reason that they're
attacking me is because they want to
attack you
and again the proof is in the pudding
because we've seen a lot of that this
week
i don't think it's holy that i think
there are some people on the left who
legitimately wants to separate between
people who supported trump it's a it's a
two-party system
people voted for trump people who are
conservative and the worst aspects of
trump
but i think that that is far from the
rule in in democratic circles at this
point which is really a problem
it's really really a problem i'll give
you a perfect example so last night
don lemon the it of the democratic party
he's just a democratic mouthpiece
so don lemon really just laid it out
there he he legitimate so chris cuomo
was with him and when chris cuomo was
the voice of reason in a room you know
things have gone wildly wrong
so chris cuomo on cnn was saying are you
really trying to suggest that every
trump supporter is responsible for what
happened
during the capital riots and zon lemon
said yeah i am
yeah i am if you supported trump you're
in league with the kkk you're in league
with capital rioters you're in league
with segregationists
here is don lemon just smearing every
single conservative in america with the
capital rights
republicans know you're doing this we
have eyes and we know that there are
consequences
to accepting that version of reality the
consequences is we
the consequence is we all get excised
and marginalized from the public
conversation and so the our answer is no
we are not going to go along with that
whatever you want us to do right that is
what is driving so much opposition
to the impeachment by republicans
because after all republicans were in
that house too
those republicans were being attacked
largely by trump trump was spending more
ire
on mike pence than he was on the
democrats trump was spending more ire on
the governor of georgia and the
secretary of state of georgia than he
was on the democratic senate candidates
republicans were trump's targets far
more than democrats were over the last
two months
he was suggesting that they were somehow
disloyal
so republicans you know are not are the
ones who are taking the brunt of trump
not democrats
and nonetheless when you lump everybody
together like this this
is the problem if you want to go forward
as a country you have to stop
lumping every single person together
with the worst aspects of the other side
you have to stop setting standards that
you yourself do not hold to here was don
lemon
doing precisely the opposite last night
if you voted for trump you voted for the
person
who the clan supported you voted
for the person who nazis support
you voted for the person who the
alt-right supports
that's the crowd that you are in you
voted for the person
who incited a crowd to go into the
capital
and and potentially take the lives of
lawmakers
took the lives of police officers took
the lives of
innocent lives who were there on the
capitol that day
you voted on that side
you voted on that side you see right you
you intentionally did it
you knew this was going to happen you
you were aware of the possibility that
this was going to happen
and you voted for that side okay you
know how easy it is
to say the same about the other side
it's really really easy to say that
every single democrat who voted for joe
biden was totally fine
with the black lives matter riots that
wrecked cities and got people killed
every single person on the left was
totally fine with antifa
after all joe biden said antifa is an
ideology here's the thing i don't think
every single democrat is okay with that
stuff
in fact i think most democrats are not
okay with that stuff i think one of the
reasons joe biden ended up as
president-elect
is because many democrats rejected that
kind of radicalism from other members of
the party
nonetheless this is the narrative from
the left and because of that narrative
there cannot be unity even in a time
where there should be unity as always as
always whenever i say there should be
unity i don't mean you have to agree
with me
i mean that there is a political
approval of the basic idea that violence
is bad in american life
90 of americans believe this but many of
the elites don't believe this
many of the people who are in media
believe that violence on one side
is okay they just think on your side
it's not okay
many of the elites believe that evidence
is unnecessary to prove
basic contentions about american life
only on their side on the other side you
need evidence right when trump says
widespread voter fraud you need evidence
when we say america is a semi-racist
country and every single
discrepancy between performance of
groups is due
to that innate american racism we don't
need any evidence of that
when you back that sort of double
standard no one is going to unify with
you because you are being dishonest you
do not deserve unity if you are being
dishonest in your standards
again the basic idea here is the
democrats goal here is not
to get rid of trump primarily the goal
is the political
goal the goal is everybody on the right
is with trump
and trump is with the rioters by the
transit of property you are with the
rioters and just like the rioters have
been excised from american life as well
they should be because they are
criminals you should also be excised
from american life this is utterly
foreseeable
you and the rioters are tied at the hip
trump is the glue that holds you and the
rioters together
and so if you voted for trump just to
oppose joe biden or you liked a lot of
what trump did but you didn't like his
personality or he liked trump's
personality but he didn't expect this to
happen
you are still glued together with the
people who decided to violate the seat
of democracy
and try to harm congress people and
legislators and the vice presidents of
the united states
people on the right see that and when
the media keep repeating that line over
and over
it's not hard to see why people on the
right believe that the social fabric is
frayed because
social fabric gets frayed when people
doubt each other's motives
okay and and when one side is basically
openly suggesting that the other side is
evil
all the time i talk about this on the
program a lot people on the left
have a tendency to believe that people
on the right are legitimately evil
in 2016 they couldn't believe that trump
won because
they thought that anyone who opposed
barack obama or hillary clinton was evil
and so their first reaction was i can't
believe there are so many evil people in
the country not maybe we were wrong
not maybe we ought to investigate the
the minds of the people who didn't vote
for us
there was about a five-minute period
where they were interested in that and
then they went right back to
trump is a white supremacist and all the
people who support him are white
supremacists
and now they get to fall back because
biden won they're now falling back
on that same hackneyed and vile
misinterpretation of american life
and impeachment is just their latest
attempt to do this
people on the right can see this so it's
really not about
what trump did for a lot of folks a lot
of folks like again i i think good
hearted people can disagree on
impeachment i have a lot of friends who
are pro-impeachment on the right i have
a lot of friends who are
anti-impeachment on the right i have a
lot of friends who are pro-censure on
the right
but what i think is that those those
arguments many of which are principled
some of which are prudential
i talked about this at length yesterday
they take a back seat overall
for the future to the broader question
of whether we can live together and if
one side of the political aisle is
determined to lump 74 million americans
minimum
because those americans have kids they
have relatives who didn't vote so you're
really talking about
easily over 120 million americans if
you're determined to lump
that many americans into one group of
deplorables
then we can't it's going to be very
difficult for us to have a country in
the future because we can't even
solidify around basic notions like
violence in politics and generally is
bad
and claims deserve evidence we can't
even unify around that
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity hit the like button